welcome to PlayStation VR you're about
to break through to an entirely new
level of gaming and it's really
important to watch this three-part video
which will take you all the way from set
up to play so let's unbox it and get you
all set up sitting right on top you'll
find a very handy quick start guide to
help walk you through the process and
inside the big box you'll find smaller
boxes crack open small box number 1 and
you'll find the printed materials PS vrs
processor unit a USB cable the AC
adapter and stereo headphones small box
number two and the main box revealed
underneath have the rest of the cables
you'll need to connect all the
components together now take out the AC
power cord the hdmi cable and the VR
headset connection cable if you have the
PlayStation camera bundle pack you'll
find the camera in here as well place
all these items aside to now reveal the
PS VR headset it's okay if you just want
to look at it for a few minutes when
you're ready move on to the next video
where you'll find out how to put all of
this together